[Music]
remember that the promise of desire is
the attainment of what you desire
that of aversion is not to fall into
what is avoided
and that he who fails in his desire is
unfortunate
well he who falls into what he would
avoid
experiences misfortune if then you avoid
only what is unnatural among those
things which are under your control
you will fall into none of the things
which you avoid
but if you try to avoid disease or death
or poverty
you will experience misfortune withdraw
therefore your aversion from all the
matters that are not under our control
and transfer it to what is unnatural
among those which are
under our control but for the time being
remove utterly your desire for if you
desire
some one of the things that are not
under our control you are bound to be
unfortunate
and at the same time not one of the
things that are under our control
which it would be excellent for you to
desire is within your grasp
but employ only choice and refusal and
these two but lightly
and with reservations and without
straining
chapter two of epictetus and caridian
talks quite a lot about desire and
aversion about aurexis
and eclasis in in the greek it also
touches on some
other matters like choice and avoidance
or nature what's natural what's
unnatural and this is a
very important part of the text because
what epictetus
is doing is setting out for us
some advice that if we want to make any
progress
in the stoic life as sketched out say in
his discourses or other stoic writings
or contained here in the end caridian
we have to make some some commitments
you might say we have to make
choices about the ways in which we
choose
we even have to make choices about the
way in which we
desire or are averse to things and i
think a lot of people find this
either puzzling or off-putting or
perhaps a little bit
daunting because what our society
tends to teach us about our entire
emotional
life is that things like desire and
aversion they just
are we have them we don't really have
control over them
but the stoic philosophy teaches that
we do indeed have some measure of
control
particularly if we look over you know a
period of time
where our decisions lead to other states
lead to new decisions
we have a lot of control over what it is
that we do in fact desire
or are averse to the ways in which we
think about things
affects the way in which we feel or what
it is that we
desire so he says remember
this is a reminder to us
remember that the promise of desire
is the attainment of what you desire
that of aversion
is not to fall into what is avoided
so it's a very interesting thing to say
there
the promise the literally here
at angelia the the news the the
announcement what it is that desire
whispers to us or shouts at us is that
we
will in fact get what it is that we
consider to be good
aversion turning away from something you
know
almost instinctively blanching at it or
feeling disgust at it or feeling fear in
the face of it
makes a sort of implicit promise to us
that we're not going to fall into that
but that's not actually the case and he
goes on and says
here we go he who fails in his desire
right we fail in our desires all the
time he says that the person who
fails in their desire is unfortunate
then he makes a contrast there the
person who
falls into what they would avoid
experiences
misfortune and the two words there are
actually very closely connected
in the greek it's atu 2k means
chance or randomness or things just
happening to turn out in a certain way
so to be
a two case is in a certain respect to
say
um you're unfortunate you're unlucky
things did not pan out
the way that you expected them to deus
touch which is what he's calling here
what happens when we fall into what
we're averse to
has been translated as misfortune it's
it's worse
for us than merely atu deus
means something bad right that's a
prefix that they use in in greek
so to fall into what we're averse to
what it is that we really don't want
what we find uh terrifying or even
fearful or
annoying or disgusting or distasteful
those sorts of things really make for a
bad experience
and we are not just unlucky but we have
the opposite we have
bad luck when we fall into them so
what can we do about that that's what he
goes on to talk about in the next
sentence
he says if then this is something that
is a choice for us
you would avoid only what is unnatural
among the things which are under your
control
you will fall into none of the things
which you avoid
so if you think about this what are all
the things that we're
constantly attempting to avoid think
about our bodies to begin with
right our bodies require a lot of
maintenance you got to bathe them or
shower them every so
often they're liable to get cut up
and you know you have to do some basic
things like trim these
these nails that keep on growing you
know if you're a man
you don't have a beard even if you have
a beard you got to keep it maintained
unless you want to look like some
you know woolly lumber jacket kind of
guy which if you do
that also takes a lot of doing itself
you know clothing putting on your
clothing each day
ironing it you know we could go on and
on and on you know
so what happens when you have you know
is used to happen
a lot with with old pens you have a pen
in your pocket and it explodes
does your day go suddenly into
misfortune
that is an example of something that is
strictly speaking
outside of your control now of course
there's some things you could probably
do don't stick pens in your
pocket don't chew on the pen which may
cause a problem there's all sorts of
things i'm just using that as an
experience that i had as a kid which
which caused me a lot of grief because
my parents were not happy when shirts
had to be
cleaned or replaced but that's something
that is strictly speaking in
external it's out of our control
what if instead of doing that
we focused on what really belongs to us
our thoughts our emotions our
long-standing patterns
that we call habits which we can observe
ourselves
falling into our assumptions
our choices are feeling of desire
or feeling of
revulsion or rejection
or disgust any of these negative things
that we can talk about
what what uh epictetus is counter posing
as the opposite of desire aversion
what if we examine those and we say i'm
not really happy
with the way that i think about things i
find myself
getting angry too easily over trivial
things
that really it doesn't help to get angry
about or
i find myself being sad about all these
things that are happening in the world
that i have no control over but find
myself responding in such a way that i i
can't do work
or i'm you know crying off in the corner
or i can't turn on the news for fear of
what's going to happen
we could go on and on with examples like
that so
those are the sorts of things that
epictetus here is calling
what is unnatural among things that are
under our control
now we should pause here and talk about
this this notion of being natural
this is something that a lot of people
get get confused about when it comes to
stoicism because there are so many
references to nature
made we're not talking about nature
simply as
what natural scientists study or
theorize about
or you know what you might see on the
discovery channel or something like that
we're talking about human nature what is
appropriate
to human beings and not just human
beings all
across the board you know for example we
do have a natural
flight or fight impulse that gets us in
a lot of trouble
epictetus wouldn't say that that just
simply following that is what's natural
what's natural is what fulfills
us as human beings what actualizes
our full potential and that is not
something that at any given point in
time
we're fully cognizant of or fully
understand
we have to make progress in fact towards
what is more natural
away from what we feel to be natural
in order to find out what truly is
natural for us we can see
a glimpse of it on the horizon and we
can
sketch the outlines of it but we don't
fully know what it is
until we've made a lot of progress so
when epictetus is talking about
applying our aversion to the things
within
us within our makeup within our psyche
that are actually unnatural he's talking
about having a bad temper he's talking
about
temptations to be uh
you know driven by greed
driven by gluttony driven by all sorts
of
bad uh in many respects not just one
respect but bad
instincts or or desires we can have
aversions to our own desires this is
what happens when you feel the pains of
conscience
when you feel regret when you look at
your life and you say i'm not really
happy with the kind of person that i am
when you abandon all of the
self-justifying
and the distancing and really look at
yourself
you're likely to find some things that
you're not entirely happy with
that is applying aversion
to those things that are under our
control but are not
natural so he goes on and he says
if you do that you'll probably make
progress but you're also
not going to fall into these other
things
if your if your focus is primarily on
how do i
prune away the parts of myself that are
that are
identifiable as bad and how do i
cultivate those parts of myself
that i can see are good so that i have
more good than
bad over time if you're really focused
on that
then if a pen explodes in your shirt
that's not going to really bother you
it can happen but the question is does
it have to bother you
do you have to feel aversion towards it
you don't
that's that's a choice he goes on
and he says
if you try to avoid disease or death
or poverty you're going to experience
misfortune
these are strictly speaking from a stoic
perspective things that are out of our
control
and you can say well you know you can
take care of yourself so you're not
going to get sick
true epictetus would completely agree
with you
as a matter of fact he says you ought to
take care of your body
but you want to take care of it like you
do a good tool
that you've been given and now are
responsible for
not as if that body is you and where all
of your value lies
you can take care of your body and
things can go haywire
you know we find all sorts of great
cures for things we we inhabit
a epoch in which medical science has
made incredible advances
and yet we still find that
disease somehow remains ahead of us
great example of this
the fact that we're now reaching the
point where antibiotics aren't working
so well anymore
and we can go on and on and on and we
can say well we can imagine a world in
which there is no disease
that's fine that's imagination that
isn't where you live
death you're going to die the mortality
rate for human beings
over any given period always approaches
100 percent
why because we die we're mortal so if
you see
death as uh you know fundamental
uh indignity that's imposed upon you
from the stoic perspective you're
actually setting yourself up for a lot
of problems
not so much when you die but before you
die
other people's death as well is
something that stoics have to deal with
poverty you know this is uh particularly
important in our own times i think when
you know we've experienced some
some massive economic downturns we're
probably approaching
a period with in which economic
realities
look a lot less like this massive period
of
more or less uninterrupted growth that
we had in the west
and more like what's been going on the
rest of history
where there's a lot of stratification
where there's a lot of
inequities a lot of unfairness and a
person can work very very hard
and still end up becoming impoverished
as a result
that is something that is strictly
speaking from a stoic perspective
outside of our control not that you
shouldn't manage your resources well
but there is no guarantee that just
because you do
things are going to go well so if we
feel a sense of aversion
a desire against poverty disease
death we are going to be unhappy because
we're sooner or later
going to run into at least one of those
and many of us will experience
all three at one point in time
so instead of being averse to those
things
why aren't we averse to what makes us
unhappy
later on he's going to talk for example
about it's not death
itself that threatens to make us unhappy
it's our
viewpoint on death that does so and we
can say this with so many other things
about
romantic disappointment about loneliness
about uh unfairness in the workplace
a lot of these things and we're not
denying that many inequities and many
bad things happen
and that people shouldn't do those sorts
of things but it's a question of
how we allow those things to affect
ourselves what we choose
where to apply our aversion
so he gives us some advice then he says
withdraw therefore you're aversion from
all the matters that are not under our
control
just take it away of course that's
easier said than done isn't it
it's not something that you can choose
once and for all
and hope to be effective it's something
that you'll have to
you know continually make that choice
like you did the day before like you did
the day before
there will be some some lack of progress
and falling back
but if you continue to do this
eventually you can redirect
your desires and your aversions to the
things that you really do have control
over
so he says transfer it to what is
unnatural among the things under your
control
look at the things that you don't like
about yourself that are really
keeping you from realizing your human
nature
and be averse to those you know when you
find yourself
feeling a sense of disgust or not
wanting to do something that you know
you're supposed to do
look at that part of yourself and
transfer your version of that say
i don't like that about myself man i
wish i wasn't that way and gradually
you're gonna you know move away from
being that way
so he says but for the time being
utterly remove your desire
that's very difficult to do
again this is a gradual process he's
talking about sort of swinging to the
opposite extreme
why because desire is constantly pulling
us in a million different directions
it and for many of us sort of just runs
our life
like a sort of theme underneath
everything else
driving away whether we realize it or
not
worse off we already inhabit a culture
in which a large
portion of that culture is devoted to
bombarding us with messages
aimed specifically at cajoling our
desire
in this direction or this direction
inflaming our desires
creating new desires where where they
didn't exist in the past
so it's kind of a good thing to do
to say i'm going to put desire on hold
for a bit it's not as if it's going to
go away totally you're never going to
get it back
so he says if you desire some one of the
things
that are not under your control you are
bound to be
unfortunate you may get what it is that
you're looking for
for a while but that is no guarantee
that you're going to hold on to
it forever or that the next time around
that you try to do the same thing that
will get you that
you're not going to fail a great example
of this is
in education i have so many students
who will turn in a paper and it's not up
to the specifications
that i explicitly gave them and they'll
say
well you know i took this class before
and
i wrote in this way for this professor
and and they thought it was great
and i'll say i'm not that professor i'm
a changed
circumstance what it is that you desire
is getting the a
but i'm going to require you to do
something different in order to get that
a
actually what you should be you know
desiring is to demonstrate to myself
and to yourself that you actually
understand
and can talk in a thoughtful way about
the things that we're putting in front
of you
in the course of this study but let's
just settle for you trying to get an
a you're going to have to do it this way
not this way
and so you know students find their
desires stymied and frustrated
constantly
we can multiply examples almost to
infinity i think you can think of plenty
of your own
about how when you allow your desire to
go out there into the world
into things that you don't control you
are setting yourself up for being
unfortunate for being unhappy so he says
and at the same time
not one of the things that are under our
control which it would be excellent for
you to desire
is within your grasp if you're
constantly focused
or even halfway focused on external
things
and trying to make sure by your own
efforts by how you're going to
shift things or frame things or leverage
things
that you're going to get at least you
know a modicum of what it is that you
want because you're not going to get it
all you're not going to have the time
you're not going to have the presence of
mind and you're not going to have the
focus
to actually work on the things that if
you did turn to
you'd have a way better percentage of
doing better in
because they depend entirely on you
and what you choose to do to rework
your own desires and aversions and your
thoughts and your feelings and
you know we can go on and on and on all
these things that fit into what
epictetus will later call the pro-racist
or moral
moral purpose or faculty of choice the
ruling part of yourself
there's a there's a choice here that has
to be made are you going to focus on
your desires and aversions towards
things that you don't control out in the
world
are you going to focus it inward on the
things that you can
actually make some real progress with so
he says
employ only choice and refusal
and this is
something that comes out of desire and
aversion right it's not exactly the same
thing as it
but we're supposed to employ it we make
a commitment you can't
will yourself to stop desiring something
this moment you can however make a
choice
to to remind yourself this is not a good
thing for me to desire
i'm going to think about this i'm going
to reflect on this i'm going to try to
work in ways that will steer me towards
realizing that other things are better
and gradually that desire will become
something under your control
and you will be able to if it's a bad
desire make it go away
have better desires in their place that
comes through
choice and refusal or avoidance
he says employ these and these two but
lightly and with reservations
and without straining that's
actually really great advice when you
first start out if you're going to try
to apply this this stuff that's in the
end caridian
it's very tempting to think oh man this
is so great i love the program that he's
laid out for me here
i'm going to do this and i'm going to
like go at it like gangbusters
and i'm going to make so much progress
he's saying no
no no no let's do little baby steps
because that's what what you're able to
do right now
you you can't do the great athletic
contest
of the soul quite yet you need to do a
bit of
training so you know we should employ
our choice in refusal
but do that lightly do that
with reservations saying okay i'm going
to
choose this but that might not work
and then i may have to reconsider my
choice or or do it again dust myself off
and recommence if we do this however
we will be setting ourselves up for
as i said making progress in
changing ourselves into the kinds of
people
that we have the potential to be and at
some bottom level
we really do desire to be we can
rediscover
deep within ourselves the desire to be
a person who would be free a person who
would be
untroubled a person who would be
beneficial to all those around
us but that's not going to happen so
long as
our desire and aversion is primarily
focused out into the world so long as
we're listening to those cajoling
promises
that desire and aversion make to us
with everything which entertains you is
useful
or of which you are fond remember to say
to yourself beginning with the very
least things
what is its nature if you are fond of a
jug
say i am fond of a jug for when it is
broken you will not be disturbed
if you kiss your own child or wife say
to yourself that you are kissing a human
being
for when it dies you will not be
disturbed chapter three of
epictetus is end coridian has what we
can call
a hard saying namely something that when
you read or when you think to yourself
or when you hear somebody else say
you can recognize that there's a kind of
validity to it
but you're like boy that would be tough
to put into practice i don't know if i
if i can do this it's almost like you
would rather
it not be true even though you recognize
a certain kind of truth to it and what
is the heart saying
it's not the one at the beginning it's
this last part
if you kiss your own child or wife say
to yourself you're kissing a human being
for when it dies you will not be
disturbed
that's a tough thing to tell yourself it
makes it sound as if you should be
rather
detached almost unemotional
callous like you shouldn't really have a
full relationship
with the people who you ought to
one would think love the most
care for the most grieve for the most
when they
pass away or when they get sick or when
something bad
happens to them and
i want to stress from the beginning that
epictetus
actually talks in his discourses
about what we can call familial
affection
uh storgia stor gaya and
he says that we ought to feel this we
ought to feel something towards our
parents towards our children towards our
spouses towards our brothers
and sisters but it's a question of how
we
manage those feelings are we
realistic about it or are we
in a certain respect over the top
about that and so he he says
this is can be understood in terms of
sort of a general class
of of matters that are outside of our
control
with everything which entertains you
is useful or of which you are fond
a lot of stuff there right so entertain
you
the tone
the things that we enjoy the things that
that literally drive our souls right
if you think about watching netflix do
you enjoy
watching a good movie or an interesting
show that where the writing is quite
clever that is something
that that he's talking about there are
there other things
of that sort do you get attached to your
sports team
do you do you follow a certain musical
group or genre and think that that
really matters
that's fine epictetus says he's not
saying
don't ever allow anything to entertain
yourself
just approach it in a certain way
everything that's useful crayon this is
an
entire category of stuff it's useful for
me to wear clothing right
this camera is a useful thing the
voice recorder that i'm using to record
right now
quite useful right the chalkboard i get
a lot of use out of this
this is a great investment that i made
there's nothing wrong with things being
useful but again
we should adopt a certain attitude
towards them
what else of which you are fond
um
he says uh stergomenol right that
is coming from that same word
for familial affection anything that
you're fond of i mean if i get attached
to this book
i can feel that you know sense of
fondness or affection towards it
you know so the book falls into the
water and gets ruined
or gets left behind somewhere you know i
can get another book
but that's my book i'm fond of it maybe
i take notes in it or you see that i
put little post-its right i'm going to
lose all of that
so epictetus is saying look you're
setting yourself up
by the way in which we naturally comport
ourselves
in relation to everything else in the
world
to feel certain things to be entertained
or amused
to find things to be useful and like
them because of that
to become fond of things so he's not
saying you're not going to
do that at all as a stoic but what
should you do
with everything of this sort
remember to say to yourself beginning
with the very least things we'll come
back to that very least things
what is its nature what is
this thing that we are dealing with
the he's not talking about nature as
fosis it's
in the greek it's hopoyonestine what
kind of
thing is it
when we think that things are different
than they are
we're setting ourselves up for all sorts
of problems because what we've got is on
the one hand
the assumption that something is
different
in a key respect like it's going to last
forever
right or it will never run into problems
or pick whatever else you want right and
we add into the mix
oh i'm fond of this thing oh this thing
is useful for me
oh i i need this thing in my life and
then we add to those one more thing
something went wrong and now suddenly
we're very upset we can't pay attention
to the things that we should pay
attention to
we we find ourselves sad angry afraid
anxious depressed despairing
we can go on and on and on so
he says beginning with the very least
things
why should we begin with the very least
things well
because again it's useful to begin with
baby steps not not trying to do
everything all at once you can't
possibly begin to live the stoic life
the way it's being sketched out
here in an ideal manner all at once
all the way across the board it is
something incremental
so i can begin for example with this tie
you know
what what is my tendency to get stains
on my ties
and then i'm like oh you know i ruined a
perfectly good tie
now i'm not going to be able to wear it
as it turns out
i've learned from experience most stains
will come out
i'm kind of a messy person i could you
know
say i have to like pay super close
attention
all the time and i could make myself
neurotic in doing so right
and deprive myself of any sort of
enjoyment i could also do things like
you know throw the tie over my shoulder
when i'm eating or tuck it in underneath
my shirt and look kind of silly
doing so that might actually be a decent
thing to do
if maintaining my tie is really such a
major
priority and i can begin with this and
then after i've got that down then i can
start thinking about
my wife my children my livelihood
my legacy you know the big big big
picture things right
uh start out with the little things and
so he gives us an example
that i think all of us can relate to if
you're fond of a jug
aren't you all of you found of jugs say
i am fond of a jug
tell yourself it's a jug that i'm fond
of
why when it's broken you will not be
disturbed you will not be troubled you
will not be
upset now i don't really
have a lot of jugs myself what i would
use to relate to it would be
i have a coffee cup i like this kind of
coffee cup
i've actually broken a few of these
which is why we've ordered
more of them and we'll probably have to
order more
in the coming years because i'm probably
going to end up breaking them
i'm a little bit clumsy when it comes to
washing dishes although i do
like to wash the dishes and sooner or
later
i'm going to you know stumble with my
fingers or put it down too hard or
something like that and i'll i'll break
it now when it breaks
i can you know get very upset and say oh
it never should have broken or i should
have never behaved that way or
the whole world is is you know off on on
its axis
or i can say well it was a coffee cup
those things are not made to last for a
million years
likewise a tie likewise a shirt now this
is something else that for myself
to take personal examples i would like
all of my shirts to last
forever because once i find a shirt that
i really like
i want to keep on wearing it the very
fact that i like it
and keep on wearing it is precisely what
makes it
wear away the fact that i wear it
and then you know sweat in it and then
wash it
and then bring it out and because i like
shirts to be more or less you know
not have a lot of wrinkles in them iron
it i'm gradually
consuming and destroying that shirt so
if i'm going to get upset
about the fact that well this shirt now
has to go away
i i'm being irrational epictetus would
say
now the question is should we look at
this only for objects
or should we apply this to persons and
if we do
apply this to persons are we treating
the persons as
objects epictetus would say no
really what happens for the most part is
is a reversal of that
we treat our objects as if they're
persons that really matter to us
that we could get fond of and then you
know have a
problem of attachment and loss and then
have to go through the whole cycle of
grief
how ridiculous is that if a coffee cup
breaks
that's that's not a great loss my child
dies
that is a great loss if my wife dies
that is a great loss when my parents
died
great loss so he says
if you kiss your own child or wife say
to yourself you're kissing a human being
remind yourself
of the very vulnerability of the human
frame
to all sorts of calamities diseases
you're not kissing something at least in
terms of the body
that is going to be forever i mean
perhaps there'll be some advances in
medical
technology that allow us to extend
lifetime
indefinitely but again that's in the
imagination right now that's in
potential that's not in reality
in reality every person that we we
encounter
we could lose them the next day we could
lose them
the next hour and so
this doesn't necessarily mean that you
can't
have fondness that you can't love your
your children love your parents love
your spouse
but you have to remind yourself of the
fact that
they are a human being just like you
like all other human beings mortality
rate of 100
over time and so when they are gone
you're not going to be as he says
disturbed or troubled the word for that
is they say
and this means to be very upset that's
not to say that you wouldn't
feel anything but you don't have to
allow your entire life to collapse
because of it so
hopefully that hard saying now once
explained isn't
quite so hard it is still difficult to
put into practice
you